près d'un million d'euros c'est le
montant de la subvention versée par la
région ile de france pour la création
d'un nouvel écoquartier à versailles
appelée quartier de gally la signature
officielle a eu lieu vendredi 3
septembre sur ce nouveau site 140
logements une école une micro ferme une
crèche montessori et des commerces faut
voir le jour notre région a besoin de
70000 logements neufs par an nous
connaissons une croissance démographique
de 50000 franciliens chaque année et
donc nous avons besoin de logements pour
permettre aux gens de vivre dignement
tout proche du domaine du château de
versailles est limitrophe à
saint-cyr-l'ecole ce nouveau quartier
s'inscrit dans le dispositif sanscartier
innovants et écologiques mises en place
par la région ile de france celle ci a
déjà labellisé 57 quartier pour
l'obtenir plusieurs critères dont
l'importance des espaces de nature avec
la création à versailles d'une cité
fertile puisque le nouveau quartier ne
doit pas être visible depuis le château
de versailles donc toute une logique
avec une des masques végétaux qui vont
être placés entre le parc du château et
les futurs bâtiments et on va être
vraiment dans un espace de nature très
bien pensé avec une grande exigence
chuter cural ce terrain de 20 hectares
est construit sur l'ancienne caserne
militaire de pions les travaux devraient
débuter dans les mois à venir puisque le
quartier de gally devra en partie être
prêt pour les jeux olympiques de 2024
les épreuves d'équitation se dérouleront
à quelques centaines de mètres de là le
projet global devra être terminée lui en